e
e e
okay you looking for your my
G I get my gavel
oh okay good morning everybody I'm gonna
open up the um subcommittee work
session for um HB
1685 redefining the homestead Foods as
Artisan Foods creating an artisan food
operations exemption establishing
Artisan food products sales venues and
allowing the production and sale of
artisan food products requiring
Refrigeration um we do not have four of
the six people who are on that
subcommittee present
so I am going to recess this
meeting
until
about well we need to have the vote and
the
recommendation
before the full committee
meets so I am going to recess this
until uh one
o'clock with hopefully uh representative
Bixby will be here and so I'm going to
recess this meeting until 1:00 and then
our 1:00 meeting for the full committee
will be right after the subcommittee
takes its vote on its
recommendation
e
e e
yes yeah yeah you were deputized to vote
with us so we were just wondering why
one of us not on the artisanal Foods
subcommittee couldn't follow that Norm
and be deputized to
vote the 24-hour notice okay
okay I'll let you get settled
yes we're gonna do the subcommittee
first
okay
so good afternoon everyone um I am going
to uh convene the meeting of the
subcommittee work
session uh for the food safety
subcommittee uh which has the members of
myself uh representative ktoa
representative Bixby and representative
Murray uh representative sofikitis and
representative kulan are unable to
attend today so with the four of us uh I
I had elected with our previous
subcommittee meeting to take a vote for
the subcommittee as to whether or not we
recommend future legislation on uh hb1
1685 or not and so I would request that
um our
members um make that
recommendation and so I am going to
um put the
um um make the motion to to recommend to
the full committee later after this uh
to recommend this bill for future
legislation uh do I hear a second I
second that thank you representative
Bixby um so I now request representative
Bixby representative Murray
representative ktoa and myself to take a
vote on that motion all in favor raise
your hand say I I
um oh yeah okay oh there you are okay so
the the U no no no not you guys no um so
the four of us then are unanimous in
recommending this for future legislation
um thank you for that vote and that's
all we really needed to do for this
subcommittee and uh thank you and I'm
going to now close that subcommittee
work
session and I will
um first request that we uh do the
Pledge of Allegiance before we uh
convene our full committee thank you
pledge of allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all thank
you so the agenda that we have at
hand is uh
to take the recommendations from our
subcommittees on HB
1170 HB 1351 and HB
1685 and um this is an exec session for
those bills for those interim study
bills to uh decide whether or not this
committee recommends them for future
legislation or
not and so uh I will open up the exec
session for HB
1170 and uh do I hear a
motion represent
ktoa uh I make a motion not to recommend
for future legislation do I hear a
second
representative representative Katon
seconds and would you like to speak to
your motion I would I don't believe uh
that the subcommittee um actually had
any recommendation as there was actually
no meeting on the topic and therefore uh
based on not really delving into the
subject I'd like to uh not recommend it
for future
legislation okay do I hear any other
discussion on representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair though there
wasn't a meeting um yet um I do believe
it is possible that we could uh recess
this potentially and have a hearing
excuse me a meeting and uh the acting
deadline uh if I'm not wrong is the
20 uh 4th um is that a possibility to do
so well then that would require the full
committee to come in once more to vote
to recommend for future legislation or
not and that would be I think kind of um
an inconvenience for most members to do
that I'm sorry
so um I believe that there
representative Bixby I believe that
there that um in order to vote to
recommend future legislation a um a
subcommittee meeting is actually not
required in order to do
that
okay uh personally I would have liked to
have had some in-depth study of the
subject
uh so that some information could be
brought to the full committee I mean I I
get that you know you don't have to but
I mean for the nature of doing an
interim study I I think that we would be
remiss in making a recommendation
without actually having done some kind
of study for that
bill um representative
Duty uh yes can you clarify the process
I mean it was my understanding that each
subcommittee had a chair and that it was
the chair's responsibility to call a
meeting that meeting was called but
there wasn't a Corum I don't what
happened the meeting was never called no
there was no
meeting okay okay representative
gerana thank you madam chair I would
just like to to say uh that you know
unfortunately we didn't have that
subcommittee
meeting I continued to do research on on
the bill I was a co-sponsor of
amendments that were offered that we
talked about in committee but Dees did
not have enough time to uh to evaluate
those uh those amendments and I wanted
to pass out to uh everyone as a reminder
just the language that we had
discussed that was presented in
amendments and in particular Madame
chair asked some very good questions
about how certain potential harmful
impacts would be would be measured
uh so one of the things that we are are
hoping to do with with an amended bill
is to have the Department of
Environmental Services weigh potential
benefits which is currently in RSA with
potential harms which is not in RSA uh
and uh what I have provided to the to
the committee by email is a link to the
federal government the Department of
Transportation federal ederal Highway
administration's website which shows
that the federal government has been
doing this since 1969 so more than 55
years the federal government has been
weighing exactly the specific kinds of
potential harms that you know we have
offered that we hope would go into
future legislation so there is a long
history of being able to calculate and
quantify measure and balance uh the
specific things that uh we are offering
as part of the net public benefit in in
an amended
bill I appreciate that and I you're and
I I appreciate the work that you may
have done um to follow up with this
legislation unfortunately I mean I
received that information last night
have no have had no time to review it at
all and I mean even even the this paper
that you're passing out I'm just seeing
this now so
you
know I I just think that since there
really hasn't been any kind of um you
know subcommitte meeting to really delve
into what kinds of things could be done
should be done shouldn't be done uh you
know we really don't have as as a
committee really have enough information
to recomend Future legislation on this
um who
who representative
representative um Murray thank you madam
no that's okay I I do want to H say that
I do think that we have heard in
previous testimony um a large um set of
findings that really um spoke to the the
need for there being a conversation on
what net public benefit actually means
and how that is quantifiable and I think
that we um as a group um did have
lengthy disc discussions on the subject
matter um I am happy
to um note that while while there may
have not been a subcommittee hearing on
the issue this the underlying issue
still remain the same that we heard in
testimony representative
kamto thank you madam chair and I
appreciate what everyone is saying but
this committee did vote for an inim
study because we wanted more information
and without that forthcoming I cannot
vote for future legislation
representative H Haskins with respect
this is a very important subject and the
information that I've been hearing and
reading without doing specific research
is replete across the media so I think
that it would be a shame not to move
this forward for future legislation
because it is about public health it is
it is ex intrinsically important to to
the issues that many of us care about so
I'm certainly going to vote in favor
okay representative
Katon thank you madam chair I guess the
way I look at this is we as a committee
looked at this last spring and we
decided that it needed a little bit more
work and there was not
uh work done on it uh as as we had
agreed uh although I see the value of
the bill and there's portion of the
bills um
I think we had an agreement with each
other that we' look at it and we'd study
a little bit more and we didn't do that
that being said uh as representative Jam
stated there's there is precedent for
this and if there is a separate bill
then that bill can be fired separately
but I think as a
committee um we've not done what we said
we were going to do and we don't have
additional information and so I would
vote not to recommend it since we have
not done our due diligence
however I would be glad to look at a
bill that took a part subsets or or
whatever of this and proposed new
legislation I think that would be a
valuable exercise
over representative uh n yeah um thank
you madam chair I just have a question
for you our representative Bixby as to
um as a sort of new still new legislator
um if we recommend the this for future
legislation then the committee would
work on that legislation versus if
somebody filed this if someone was to
file new legislation related to this
this fall what is the difference between
us recommending it for future
legislation and as representative kryon
said um filing related legislation this
representative Bixby yeah so um
functionally there is no difference uh
so uh the recommendation of a when we
voted interim study we basically killed
the bill for this term and
no no the actions of one term can't bind
the next term so um the only thing that
um an a a recommendation for future
legislation would do would um provide a
little bit of a um sort of moral boost
but it doesn't have but it has
absolutely no legal bearing whatsoever
on what comes forward for another bill
so if the commit if we don't recommend
for future legislation on this then um I
think that the next step would be to uh
for all those who are interested in this
bill to work with uh Nick on sponsoring
it for next
term yep representative ger thank you uh
I I understand kind of the argument
that's being made I appreciate it that
we recommended it for interim study
unfortunately the interim study didn't
happen uh I do just want to point out
however that when we're when if the
committee were to vote in favor of
future Rec future legislation that's not
a vote in favor of specific future
recommendation that's not an endorsement
of the specific language in the original
bill or of the amendment right a vote in
favor of future legislation is a
recognition that what we have now is a
system that makes no sense what we have
now is a system in which making a
decision you draw up a pro list and not
a con list and what we should have a
system that requires us to draw up a pro
list and a con list and to balance those
two to determine where we go from there
in my mind that's all a vote in favor of
recommending future legislation does it
says that this committee agrees that
legislation that requires a net public
benefit analysis is the direction that
we should be going without endorsing any
specific language or approach thank you
represent Duty uh yes thank you madam
chair uh yes I would vote in favor of uh
What uh representative germano said in
terms of future legislation and the
reason for that is I went through to
many of the dees uh meetings regarding
the ashalt plant in naswa and my
understanding of the way the law is now
okay the only input a resident can have
is is based on scientific information
that they can dispute or support uh
during that that meeting in other words
they can't bring in issues like noise
pollution they can't bring in uh they
couldn't bring in issues of um diesel
fuel for from trucks that were idling
because that was outside the purview of
the scientific data um and I think this
bill uh supports the fact that um
individuals should be able to come
forward and put those arguments forth um
because it does affect their daily life
so I uh believe in the concept of this
bill and I would want to see this
concept going forward uh in the next
session okay thank you any other
comment seeing none I'd like the uh
clerk to call the role on the the uh
proposed
motion I I will so the motion on the
table for HB 1170 is not to recommend
for future legis
representative
kraton not to recommend right I
recommend I not to recommend just make
sure I get my vote right yes to not
recommend I do not recommend yes
represent coma yes uh representative
Davis yes uh representative Kenny yes
representative smart representative
Bixby no Representative dsy no
representative Murray no representative
Jama no represent H Haskins no represent
NAB no and represent biman
no what that mean oh Madam chair you're
yes you're at the top I always have to
go
back the motion fails
67 thank you represent miby yes I move
that we recommend further legislation
any
discussion I think we've discussed it
who who made the
second I think no somebody already J
Jama by representative
Bixby
okay please call the role for the um
thank thank you madam chair so uh this
is to recommend uh HB 1170 for future
legislation representative kraton no
representative coma no representative
Davis no representative Kenny no
representative
smart represent Bixby yes represent Duty
yes represent Murray yes represent jamna
yes represent H Haskins yes represent
NAB represent bman yes motion passes 76
oh Madam
chair no 76 thank you
okay I'm going to close the exec session
on HB 1170 and I'm going to open the
exec session on HB
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps and I would
uh request that chair of um The
subcommittee Who reviewed that um bill
or discussed that bill uh representative
Bixby please um give your subcommittee's
recommend ation on that uh the
subcommittee recommended on a 4 to1 vote
that uh we do not proceed with further
legislation uh
and uh the basis for that was
essentially that uh we didn't see what
uh we didn't see what that what that LE
potential legislation would actually
look like and there was not a proposal
that was different than what the
previous legislation that did not um
get approval was okay thank you would
you like to uh uh make a motion oh
um
I I guess I as as as chair of that
subcommittee I will um move what the
subcommittee recommended which is not to
to recommend no further legislation okay
represent kto I'll second that thank you
uh any discussion on that representative
H Haskins yes thank you you um as the
dissenting vote I have to say that I did
a pretty poor job of presenting my
um opinion about this topic oh you never
do a poor
job thank you um I think a lot of it had
to do with the fact that I really didn't
understand what interim study was and
I've had this conversation with
representative Bixby who was equally
kind about it but I don't feel very good
about it
um nevertheless I think that this topic
about which there is much new
information remains what I called it
originally a 19th century solution to a
rodent problem I introduced the idea
which some of you already know
contraception for rodents which is a
indeed 21st century um option for this
topic um
I also said that there is indeed
evidence that unintended animals are
being caught in these glut traps that
they are inhumane they represent torture
fish and game is against them there's a
lot of testimony by wildlife sanctuaries
that work with the critters that get
caught on these things and it just it
strikes me that we can do better than
that which is why I voted um for future
legislation which I surely will be part
of thank you for that um I would just
like to add um before I go to
representative com's comments
um that yes I mean I see that
contraception and that there are other
means by which to control rodents but
with regard to the glue traps
themselves um I believe that you know
personally I just don't want to
eliminate
a non-chemical form of rodent control
from the toolbox of those who can use it
and places that have
been um ens snaring non-targeted species
simply have been using them in the wrong
places that they should not so I mean I
I I I I also agree that um for for
purposes of uh prohibiting adhesive base
rodent traps I would support um no on
future legislation and representative
kto you had some comments thank you
madam
chair
so you know I as I discussed in our inim
study I was at a farm bureau meeting and
we were discussing different ways to
control rodents obviously contraception
came up as one of the ideas and was
acknowledged that it is working so that
is an
option however
they want more options and when I hear
and I'm not disputing the fact that
adhesive traps may be using Outdoors
it's really hard for me to understand
how that stickiness is uh if you get
sand on it or anything it basically you
know nothing really sticks to it um um I
went out after that hearing and
purchased uh one of
the non-toxic organic that was highly
recommended that I was told that worked
100% that the person no longer had any
rodents at their home I mean not only I
scrubbed the area I triple sprayed
everything and it did not
work
um because I wanted to see if in true
there was another option for me to
use it was
not um sticky traps is only one tool in
the
toolbox we are getting ready I think
that we understand that the second
generation coagulants are going to not
be able to be used by individuals so
you're eliminating another tool for
controlling rodents rodents are a public
health
Menace and we need to have all the
non-toxic Tools in our
toolbox uh to be able to control them in
and around our Farms our feed our homes
and I think as you're seeing so you know
we had the discussion some people at
that meeting were like oh no I would
never use them and we're like great and
other people are like we really need it
as a tool so people already have the
option of whether they want to use them
or not um so I think that eliminating a
non-toxic
uh way to control them would be
detrimental in a lot of instances
thank
you representative
Duty thank you madam chair um I have two
points to make unfortunately I was not
able to attend the subcommittee meeting
but I did um uh provide uh the chair
representative uh Bixby with some of U
my concerns and ideas uh one of the
things that I think we should be doing
is we should be putting a label on all
of those packages that that basically
say uh this product has been deemed uh
inhumane for uh wildlife and may
inadvertently catch uh pets or whatever
you know uh in the Trap I think to put
some type of a warning label on it so
the consumer knows that Wildlife
organizations do consider this to be an
inhumane treatment uh I would be helpful
and it doesn't ban the product uh
secondly okay secondly uh and and that
has hasn't been discussed here so I just
wanted to bring it up secondly I
recently uh watched a webinar um that
was Raptors um as a biological weapon
against rats and in that they indicated
that one Raptor will eat three rats a
day and that barn owls that my
understanding are we do not have in this
area for you know um uh for perpetuity
because of the cold Winters but barn
owls eat5 100 rats a year yet what we do
is we have escar okay that in infect the
rats that eat it the Raptors eat the rat
and then we kill the Raptors because of
of what they've eaten so we're
inadvertently killing the uh non-toxic
remedy that we have and it seems to me
that uh Farms are a perfect environment
you know for um for Raptors
uh I don't know all about it but I know
I guess what they're saying is you know
if you want Raptors put a raptor perch
in your yard or on your land and you'll
get Raptors um so I think those are some
of the things that we should be thinking
about and talking about and you know I
um would agree with representative H
Haskins and I would vote um for moving
this legislation along not this
particular piece of legislation but the
concept and I do think labor in is a
place to start representative
kto thank you madam chair um and
representative Duty thank you uh for
that um I do have Raptors um I get to
I'm one of the very fortunate people and
I get to watch them uh sore The Thermals
um when I'm outside um and I watch them
go down and get the rodents and
everything and it does help but it
isn't the O It's not 100% solution um
and once they're in your home or in a
building those Raptors can't get to
those rodents and that's why we need the
uh the tools in the
toolbox representative
Kenny um I agree that Raptors will go to
uh eat rodents but when you have
chickens chickens are easy targets so I
do not want r Raptors around my chicken
Coupe cuz I've lost too many hens to
Raptors so I agree we need tools in the
toolbox thank you representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair the tool
in the toolbox argument is interesting I
would wager that when they introduce
second generation
anti-coagulants anti is that yeah scars
I'll call them scars it's easier to
remember they said it was a necessary
tool in the toolbox and now the federal
government is prepared to say it's a
lethal tool so we don't want it in the
toolbox I would say if we have to label
something as even potentially
inhumane why are we selling it if it's
inhumane so I respect the fact that um
my colleague and friend Duty uh
representative Duty um suggests that the
labeling might be the way to go but
that's what I get stuck on not to make a
pun that was inadvertent that if they
are inhumane we shouldn't be selling
them again the 20 first century is
offering us Solutions we need not when
we know better we have to do better we
need not go back to this ancient way of
capturing mice kittens whoever ever
winds up on these glue traps I just
can't imagine that we're still talking
about them yeah thank you I I'm I I am
aware that um from the from the box that
uh representative ktoa brought in that
there there is labeling on these um on
these items that say do not use these in
open places that they should be enclosed
indoors used indoors where um Birds
kittens snakes whatever would not be
the non-targeted species would not be
involved so I think you know for
purposes of labeling we already have
labels on them and I think that there is
um probably a good public
education effort going on as to you know
people's perception of it being inhumane
or cruel so there are people who are not
buying them simply because they agree
with that um but there are people who
are buying them and using them because
it is a means by which they can control
the rodent population without the use of
chemicals food safety you know food uh
preparation places um schools um places
where you don't want
chemicals involved and to ban that
completely I think would be a big
mistake because it does have a use it
does have a place
and um people just need to know better
how to implement these kinds of um these
kinds of control methods so that's my
thought on that any other discussion or
can we go to the
vote I represent dsy just say quickly
for rodents indoors you have cats okay
and and they are and I have three cats
they are very effective I don't have if
I have any rodents in the house it's
rodents they bring in we catch them and
uh take them outside that's number one
the other two the labeling that they
have right now doesn't specifically say
that per Wildlife organizations this
product is considered inhumane and
that's different I mean look at what
they did with cigarettes this product
may cause cancer boom you still want to
smoke you kin we're not Banning
cigarettes but this product may cause
cancer and I would say the same thing
this product is deemed
inhumane to Wildlife by conservation
organizations you can still buy it you
can still use it but I think that's much
more effective than saying you know be
careful where you put this okay thank
you for
that uh representative Bixby um not all
cats are very good
mousers we have we we currently have one
cat we had two cats siblings um
they would play catch and
release and the mouse might or might not
survive but um you know one mouse that
has been thoroughly played out over the
course of two days uh I'm not sure that
a glue trap is any worse than
that okay um I would like the clerk to
call the role on this
motion okay so HB
1351 is not recommended for future
legislation representative
kraton I representative ktoa yes
represent
Davis represent Kenny yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent Duty
no representative
Murray yes representative Jama no
represent H Haskins no represent NAB no
represent bman no Madam chair
yes 8 to five uh legislation is not
recommended okay I'm going to close the
exec session on HB
1351 and we'll move on to the exact
session for HB
1685 redefining home stre Homestead
Foods as Artisan Foods creating an
artisan food operations exemption
establishing Artisan food products sales
venues and allowing the production and
sale of artisan food products with
requiring
Refrigeration um I'm going to start by
saying as chairman of the subcommittee
uh the food safety subcommittee our
subcommittee met and discussed this um
Bill we had a a nice presentation by
members of Department of Health Heth and
Human Services food safety division who
gave us um presentation about you know
what the current food safety and
Homestead food laws
are um we had some food producers that
also attended that subcommittee meeting
and members of the subcommittee of
course were there and we had a a a good
discussion about um some of the
shortcomings of the current laws and
some ideas about where
uh changes could be made to the food
safety and Homestead food uh
rsas so um with that and the committee
did the subcommittee did meet briefly
this morning and unanimously uh the four
of us uh representative kamis Bixby and
Murray uh voted uh to recommend yes on
future legislation on this particular
bill
um seeing that we
have uh already some ideas uh from DHHS
as well as um food producers and members
of the subcommittee I would uh
wholeheartedly have this committee um
recommend yes on future legislation for
this bill so do I hear uh um a motion
for um for this
bill I'll make a motion representative
kto thank you madam chair I'll make a
motion that we recommend HB 1685 for
future legislation do I hear a
second representative
Kenny okay any would you like to speak
to your motion please represent com talk
thank you madam chair
um we had a really nice meeting kind of
like a round table almost for our inum
study um a uh good presentation from uh
DHHS and a lot of good information came
out of this um hearing that we had and a
lot of great ideas uh DHHS has already
come up with some ideas as uh
representative eron just said as along
with some others um we found some holes
in the law and some loopholes that um
are some things that really need to be
corrected uh to make it easier for
people to uh produce in their kitchen
and um you know we knew that this bill
itself was not ready for prime time but
because of the interim study uh a lot of
great ideas have come forth and I think
it'll have an impact on people in New
Hampshire thank you representative Bixby
yeah um I I unfortunately I was not able
to make it to that uh subcommittee
meeting but um I've sort of been looking
at the the process and looking at uh
who's been involved in it and uh my my
feeling is that uh as long as we involve
uh food Protective Services in the
drafting of the bill so that uh we know
that that we're putting together
something that they would feel
comfortable enforcing I would be uh I I
would strongly encourage this sort of
legislation thank you any other
comments then I would oh represent
NAB um I just have a question for the
subcommittee is so is this essentially a
brand dat rebranding of the idea of
Homestead Foods is that the big picture
goal of this um no but there
will the ideas that were discussed was
to uh work on
expanding um some of the food offerings
that our local producers can produce and
sell um and how they sell them to make
it easier for them to to sell them um so
you know I I think the the whole notion
of really um balancing risk management
uh with food production versus food born
illness is really at the Crux of what
we've been looking at and um so I think
that I don't know if that answers your
question but yeah okay another aspect of
it is that uh the way that the both the
statutes and the regulations are written
right now it's uh very it's fairly
confusing for people who want to get
involved in it and it's not a matter of
branding it's a matter of making the
procedures more straightforward and more
aligned with what people can actually do
so for instance one suggestion was uh
there there exists a um an occasional
food producer program where you can
without um further licensing you can
produce food for uh for sale in your
home at the moment uh under uh four
times a month four times in in 30 days
and one of the things that was brought
up was was well if that's four times in
30 days then it is not you can't
establish a weekly schedule like I'm
going to have this available every
Wednesday uh so uh by doing things like
shifting that to 28 days it makes it
that makes it possible for people to uh
do it more effectively and so and that
that's just one example of the sorts of
tweaks in existing statutes and
regulations that could make a lot easier
for people to do
it I agree okay totally agree on that if
you're going to put in a bill on that
I'll
co-sponsor this was part of what you
suggest yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay uh anyone any other
comments seeing none I'd ask the uh
clerk to call the role on this thank you
madam chair so it's HB 1685 and it is
recommended for future legislation
representative kraton I represent kto
yes representative Davis representative
Kenny yes representative smart yes
representative Bixby yes represent Duty
yes represent ger yes represent Murray
yes represent H Haskins yes represent
NAB yes represent ban yes Madam chair
yes 130 motion passes wonderful thank
you I'm going to close the exec session
on hb1
1685 and I I am extremely happy that the
very last vote that this committee has
is a unanimous
one Bravo to you all to us
all um for these three votes that we
took uh the the person who made the
motion on the bills uh I would
appreciate a very brief um committee
report just
uh it's just could be a sentence or two
which is what we need to provide our uh
provide our uh committee
assistant so
um is there any other business anybody
would like to bring up
um because um other than that I I just
want to thank this committee immensely
for a very um productive and enjoyable
uh
bium um I am very very pleased with um
the work that we've
accomplished and
uh I will miss all of
you some of
you um and um I hope you all have
a very productive fall and uh and a
great uh winter season representative H
Haskins I believe we know we have a
couple of colleagues who are not
returning to us and I wanted to thank
them um Lisa and Sher um anybody that
I'm
missing um I mean yes Karen right yeah
um enjoy getting to know you both and
will miss you and um I'm sure that you
are looking forward to a a lovely
retirement from this particular
activity in yes there you
go I expect we'll see representative
Duty again yes
uhuh thank
you okay thank you and with that I'm
going to adjourn um environment and
agriculture of the house thank you good
job Madam chair thank you